(Zac screaming into pillow)
(heavy metal music)
- Yeah, that's an accurate response.
- Welcome to "Things You Missed."
We sure wish we missed this one.
Jimmy, how did this all come together?
- The first title they came up
with was "Halloween: The Homecoming."
But the producers switched it,
because after "Halloween: H20's" ending,
they were nervous people
would only show up
if they knew for a fact
Michael Myers was back to life.
The director of "Halloween II"
was brought back for this one,
but he was actually the third choice
after Whitney Ransick,
who I personally, unfortunately,
have never heard of,
sorry if they're like huge
director or something like that,
(gentle music)
and Dwight H. Little, the
director of "Halloween 4,"
who I really would've
liked to see come back.
I think he deserved a
second shot at "Halloween."
But neither of them wanted to,
so they went with Rick Rosenthal.
- Ah, yes, our old friend, Rick.
Not Rick Moranis, not Ric Ocasek,
hell, not even Rick Astley,
Rick Rosenthal, the director
of "Halloween II" from 1981.
Rick was put in a pretty
tough spot to be fair.
Retconning the end of "H20"
by saying that Michael Myers
wasn't the one who got killed
was never gonna be popular.
And killing off Laurie Strode
in the first 10 minutes
is maybe even a bigger slap
in the audience's face.
- But remember, while old Rick
might be the one who delivered that slap,
his hand was guided by Malek Akkad.
So given the hand he was
dealt, did he do an okay job?
- Not even remotely.
Let's get into the "Things
You Missed," before I puke.
Sponsored by Ridge Wallet,
the slim, modern wallet
that holds up to 12 cards,
plus cash, in over 30 colors,
including carbon fiber and burnt titanium.
It's durable and comes
with a lifetime warranty.
Plus, every dollar you
spend on Ridge Wallet
before September 30th
enters you to win a brand
new, upgraded Ford Bronco.
Check out the link in the description
and use code: CZSWORLD for 10% off.
(air whooshing)
(eerie upbeat music)
The film begins with Laurie Strode
locked away in a sanitarium
after going crazy,
after killing a paramedic
whom she believed to be Michael Myers.
As much as we're gonna crap on this movie.
- And believe us, we are
going to crap on this movie.
- You have to give it a tiny bit of credit
for introducing some ideas
that were used years later
in "Halloween," 2018,
and "Halloween Kills"
in a much better way.
- Both "Resurrection"
and "2018" used the idea
of Laurie being the crazy one now,
and in "Resurrection,"
they take it even farther
by putting her in the
sanitarium instead of Michael.
The established roles are reversed,
she's even gone mute in this one.
- [Welles] She hasn't
said a word in years,
extreme dissociative disorder.
Now all she does it stare out that window.
- Coincidentally, staring out the window
is just what Michael
does in the Myers' house
in "Halloween Kills."
Laurie is just like Mike.
- Not to be confused with "Like Mike,"
which also came out in 2002,
and from what I remember,
was a much better movie.
The intro also features Laurie
setting a trap for Michael,
something that's used
later in "Halloween," 2018,
and this very specific scenario
of someone getting
injured on the staircase
in the Myers' house with
Michael about to strike,
before getting distracted and drawn away
by another potential victim.
This exact circumstance is seen again
later in "Halloween Kills."
There's even a line early on,
likening Michael Myers
to a great white shark.
- He's the great white
shark of our unconscious.
- I'll talk about this more in depth
in a future horror history,
but the filmmakers actually
used "Jaws" as a template
for Michael Myers in the 40-year trilogy.
- [Nelson] And it ended up being
this very strange mannequin-like,
you know, soulless,
almost great white shark of a human.
(intense music)
- Love that guy.
Oh, and don't forget that Laurie
is the one dropped from the rooftop
during the intro sequence,
just like she was in "Halloween," 2018,
which is a reversal of what happens
in the original "Halloween,"
where Michael is the one who falls
and feels the relentless pull of gravity.
- We first meet Laurie in
her cell at the sanitarium,
and she's got this rag doll,
similar to the doll seen in
her room way back in 1978.
Later on, the same doll is seen
on the desk of our
protagonist, Sara Moyer,
perhaps this was old
Rick's way of telling us
that Sara is the new protagonist now.
- The interesting thing
I learned back in 2018,
when I reviewed this movie,
is that the lead actress, Bianca Kajlich,
actually can't scream.
So every time you hear
her scream in this movie,
it's dubbed, and that gets even weirder
when you consider that the whole reason
she's in the Myers'
house in the first place
is because she's supposedly
the ultimate screen queen.
It's kind of weird, but ultimately,
it's like the least of
this movie's problems.
- The perfect introduction
to the level of care
put into this movie can be
observed in these two nurses,
Phillips and Welles, that's W-E-L-L-E-S,
even though it's spelled
differently in the end credits.
To be fair, "Halloween" 1 and 2
also had errors in the end credits
stating that Michael
Myers was 23 years old,
rather than 21.
Another patient at the
sanitarium is named Harold,
who is more true crime
obsessed than my mom.
We first see him hiding behind this tree
as the security guard patrols the grounds,
maybe the only intentionally creepy moment
that the movie has to offer.
He's wearing a clown costume,
which brings memories of the
original "Halloween" opening,
where Michael Myers sported
a clown suit of his own.
But he's actually dressed
as John Wayne Gacy,
a fellow Illinois-born serial criminal,
who performed as a clown
for children's events.
- He means fellow to Michael Myers,
not fellow to himself.
Right, Zac?
- No comment.
Like Michael, most of Gacy's
victims were teenagers
ranging an age from 14 to 21.
Being old Rick's first foray
into the "Halloween"
franchise in 21 years,
"Resurrection" has a lot of
callbacks to "Halloween II,"
whether it be the shot of the night guard
locating Michael on the security monitors,
the opening taking place in the hospital,
or even this scene where a
character slips and falls
in a puddle of red arterial fluid.
We saw the medic, Jimmy,
do just that back in the second movie.
- Literally every time
you say that, I look over,
you'd think I'd be used to that by now.
- Yeah, this is your eighth
time being on this channel,
which means this is going
to be the sixth time
that we talk about
"Halloween's" white sheet motif,
'cause it's not in "Halloween" 3 or 4.
- Michael appearing behind bedsheets
sort of became a meme
after the first movie
and plenty of the sequels took note.
In "Halloween Resurrection,"
the security guard, Willie,
investigates the laundry room
where we see a basket of bedsheets.
And then, a minute later he discovers
his partner's blood in
the laundry machine,
which is similar to "Halloween
6" where John Strode,
the most hateable
character in the franchise,
goes into the basement of his house
and finds the aftermath
of his wife's encounter
with Michael Myers.
I did not mean for that to
sound as dirty as it did.
- We first meet our main
character, Sara Moyer,
in the middle of one
of her college classes.
Yeah, Haddonfield University is back
after its first appearance
in "Halloween: The
Curse of Michael Myers,"
and the professor is a
cameo from none other
than old Rick himself.
His character's name is Dr. Mixter.
- Dr. Mixter's class, I'm
taking that course too.
- Which was the name of the
head physician at the hospital
back in Rick's "Halloween II."
Can we call it that?
- I mean, people call the 2009 entry
Rob Zombie's "Halloween II,"
so I don't really see a problem with it.
He's also giving a lesson on
the collective unconscious,
which is the main theme
explored in "Halloween II,"
where Laurie's relationship to Michael
is buried deep within
her unconscious mind.
If you wanna know more about that,
we actually talked a lot about it
in the "Halloween II" "Things You Missed."
- Our Rick's "Halloween
II" "Things You Missed."
- Exactly, after class,
Jen and her friends
scootered through campus
where you can see a poster
for a Halloween dance.
This is probably a different dance
than the one Laurie and Annie made plans
for in the original "Halloween,"
'cause that was for a high school dance
and these posters are on a college campus.
But it still brings back
memories of the original
and eventually "Halloween," 2018.
- "Halloween Resurrection" is
all about this reality show
called "Dangertainment,"
which planned to send six college students
to investigate the Myers'
house on Halloween night.
With the contestants selected,
the fun, or lack thereof,
would soon begin,
and as always, it would contained
a few "Things You Missed."
(intense music)
(eerie upbeat music)
The producer of
"Dangertainment" is this guy,
Freddie, whose interests
include saying profanity
and watching old Kung Fu movies.
The latter is a foreshadowing
for his character
who would use martial arts
to attack Michael Myers.
- Agh!
- To get ready for the
"Dangertainment" shoot,
Sara and Jen shop for
clothes in a boutique
next to a grocery store
which proudly displays
a "Dracula 2000" poster.
I've never seen a supermarket
promoting a horror movie before,
so it's obvious that this is here
because "Resurrection" is
made by Dimension Films,
who also made "Dracula 2000."
We saw Dimension trying to
promote their other properties
in the last two "Halloween" movies,
"The Curse of Michael Myers" and "H20."
Dimension is also owned by Miramax,
who released the 1994
classic "Pulp Fiction,"
which could explain why college
students Myles and Scott
dress up his characters
from "Pulp Fiction"
for a costume party.
I can't think of any
other significant reason
for this reference, can you?
- No, that makes sense because
"Pulp Fiction" is awesome.
And also, I just remembered,
"Superbad" follows the same
structure as "Pulp Fiction,"
and I think that's what makes it
the best comedy of all time.
- Also, when Sara is browsing
costumes with her classmates,
she briefly sees Michael
Myers in a reflection,
but turns immediately
to find some random kid.
This moment is never explained.
The only thing I can figure is that Sara
had expressed thoughts about
dropping out of the show
due to being too freaked out to sleep.
Maybe she started having hallucinations
of Michael Myers as well.
Whatever the case may be,
the scene is a big callback
to "Halloween 4: The
Return of Michael Myers,"
where Jamie Lloyd similarly
sees the boogieman in a mirror
while browsing costumes and freaks out.
(Jamie screaming)
Michael's boutique store visit
isn't the only appearance of his
that goes completely
unexplained in the movie.
When "Dangertainment" contestant Bill
sneaks up on Jen to scare her,
the camera glitches out
for no apparent reason,
and during which we see
one frame of Michael Myers.
None of them have encountered
Michael yet at this point,
so it's not like this is supposed
to be a "Cloverfield" like effect
where we're seeing
previously recorded footage.
You could say that this was more
of a "Malignant" type of thing,
where Michael found a way to
telepathically communicate
through audio and video devices.
But again, that's not something
that ever happens in this movie.
This same kind of thing happens again
at the end of the movie,
but this time on the news cameras,
which makes even less sense,
because they weren't even there
for anything that happened in the house.
The sad thing is I actually
really like the idea
of a found footage "Halloween" movie.
The franchise is so stale
and I think approaching Michael
Myers through found footage
could be a great way to make
him scary and mysterious again.
But this ain't it, Rick, this ain't it.
- "Friday the 13th" almost came back
as a found footage movie
after the 2009 reboot.
But for a variety of reasons,
that version of the movie
never got off the ground,
and still all these years later,
I really would like to see it.
- As Freddy's assistant,
Nora, gets ready for the show,
she gets up to grab coffee
while dancing to a song she knows.
The camera tilted down to her ass,
and then back up,
so we can see what she's actually doing
is one of the most blatantly forced
eye-candy moments I've ever seen.
They easily could have
just used a different lens
to get some booty in frame.
But no, our boy Rick was
down bad on this one.
Nora also calls a tow truck
to remove a car parked
in front of the house.
Given the level of care
put into this movie,
I'm sure the fact that the
license plate says 6395
bears no real significance.
But as someone who was
always on the lookout
for Easter eggs and secrets,
my initial thought was
that these were the years
that the initial "Halloween"
timeline took place.
It started when Michael was a kid in 1963
and ended when Michael
confronted Loomis for the
final time in 1995, 63 and 95.
- Coincidence, I think.
- Yes!
- Besides, none of the other
license plates in the film
seemed to reference anything notable.
The characters split
off into three groups.
And, of course, we
followed the two characters
who weren't even in the
movie before this point,
save for one quick soundbite.
So why would we care
what happened to them?
There's definitely some
flirtation going on between them,
but the girl, Donna,
has a comeback that cuts
even deeper than Michael Myers' knife.
- Besides, screwing a music major
would be tantamount to lesbianism.
- I'm pretty sure John Carpenter,
the director of the original "Halloween,"
was a music major at
Western Kentucky University
before transferring to USC to study film.
So that line is either a really funny jab
or a painfully awkward mistake.
- I don't know the exact relationship
between Rosenthal and Carpenter,
but based on what Carpenter has said
about "Halloween II" over the years,
I would guess this line is intentional.
Speaking of "Halloween I,"
Sara finds herself in a situation
that's very comparable to
what happens to Laurie Strode.
She investigates a shuttered closet
and gets scared by a
dummy that falls on her.
Her friend Rudy,
instead of simply opening the closet,
just punches his hands
straight through it,
which is obviously reminiscent
of what Michael does
when Laurie is the one
trapped in the closet
at the end of "Halloween I."
This is what we call a dumb Easter egg.
Not only does it not add
anything to the movie,
but everyone who just saw it
is dumber after witnessing it.
Down in the basement,
donna is scared by a rat,
which is something that happens
in the only other movie in this franchise
where the Myers' house is
shown to have a basement,
"Halloween 5: The Revenge
of Michael Myers."
Basically, if you see a
Myers' house with a basement,
you can assume you're in for a bad time.
Donna later discovers that Michael
has been surviving in the
basement by eating rats,
and that's a callback
to the original movie
when Brackett and Loomis
discover the half-eaten
dog in the Myers' house.
- It is also in this basement
where she stumbles upon this
article about Laurie Strode.
I guess this is supposed to tell us
that Michael has been keeping
tabs on her all this time,
which we already knew from "H20,"
and we don't really need to know
because Laurie's already dead.
Donna reads out the supposed headline.
- [Donna] "Laurie Strode,
sister of Michael Myers,
survives Halloween night massacre."
- Which doesn't match what
the text actually says.
"Laurie Strode has been nominated
by the Chamber of Commerce
as the most commonly," something "teen."
I can't make out what that word is.
I spent like 10 minutes
trying to figure it out
and was not willing to
waste any more of my life
with a minute detail from
the worst "Halloween" movie.
- Zac and I took a super close look
and we both think it says, "Spirited,"
but, "the most commonly spirited teen"
doesn't really make sense.
So I don't really know or care.
It's just weird, and we
wanted to point it out.
- The picture chosen for the
article is interesting though.
It's actually this behind-the-scenes photo
taken during the production
of the original "Halloween,"
and during the scene where Laurie waits
for a pick-up from Annie
right outside her house.
If anyone wants to make their
own version of this photo,
you can still go to the location,
and they even leave a
pumpkin out to use as a prop.
- Donna nearly hooks up with
her fellow contestant, Jim.
Yes, another Jim in the
"Halloween" universe.
It's getting old at this point.
Which, by the way, is really stupid,
because the whole reason
they're there is to be filmed
and they know they're on camera,
so why wouldn't you just wait
till after the show to hook up?
After this, Donna gets dressed
and explores the basement more,
which is when she has her
encounter with Michael Myers.
He kills her by impaling
her on this crooked beam
that's sticking out of the gate,
during which she is somehow
magically wearing a bra again,
which is weird,
because earlier we saw
her put her shirt back on
and she's very clearly not wearing a bra.
I just can't believe Rick
would let this slide.
- Once the bloodshed
begins, it doesn't stop.
But if we take a closer
look at some of these kills,
we can find a few more anomalies.
(thunder rattling)
(eerie music)
Another "Halloween" franchise trope
that happens in this movie
is the one where someone is
mistaken for Michael Myers
and pays the price for it.
The first time we saw
this was with Ben Tramer
in Rick's "Halloween II," RIP,
then Ted Hollister in "Halloween 4."
(slow violin music)
Then, Spitz in "Halloween 5."
In "Halloween Resurrection,"
it's the producer, Freddie.
We can actually see the
Michael Myers mask on his desk
before he goes into the house with it
and gets attacked by Jim.
Unlike Ben, and Ted, and
Spitz, Freddie survives.
Sara's friend Jen is not so lucky.
She gets decapitated by the
real Michael Myers, not you,
after which we can see the
inside of the mannequin's neck.
They didn't add any visual effects here
to make it look real.
I normally don't mind cheesy effects
in a low-budget horror movie,
but the problem here
is that one of the plot
points of this movie
is literally that the house
is filled with mannequins
and Halloween decorations
staged by the "Dangertainment"
production team.
So it's unclear if we're
supposed to believe
that Jen's death is staged or real,
which is exactly how the internet viewers
at the Halloween party react.
Myles thinks it's real
and calls the police
and gets connected immediately,
because the makers of this movie
have no idea how a phone call works.
- Hello, 911?
- [Urmaker] This has been real 911 calls
that actually happened.
- Rudy is the next character
to confront Michael.
I know his whole character
is him being a chef
and all he thinks about is nutrition,
but I love how that's still the only thing
he talks about as he's
facing certain death.
- [Rudy] You should try
a little less protein
in your diet, you know?
Control some of that aggression, huh?
- I don't even know if that's a thing.
The only reputable study
I've been able to find
linking protein and
aggression was studying dogs.
- Do you think dogs are
a good source of protein?
- I don't wanna find out,
but according to this movie,
rats are a perfectly
fine source of protein.
Rudy gets to be the victim
of the knife pin kill,
also known as the Bob Simms kill,
the Kelly Meeker kill,
the Nurse Mary kill, the Dave kill,
whatever you wanna call it.
Sara ends up being the
only remaining contestant,
so Myles, also known as Deckard,
sends her text messages
to alert her of Michael's
position in the house.
Like this one, where he informs her
that Michael is in the hallway
and says, "Don't scream,"
to which she immediately screams.
(Sara screams)
What a dumbass, she's even
worse than Nina from "Saw 7."
- Why wouldn't you just
shut the (censored) up?
- Sara climbs out through the window
onto the roof to escape,
which might be a callback
to Rachel and Jamie in "Halloween 4."
I'm gonna believe it is
because I love "Halloween 4."
I also find it really funny
that Michael opens the
window by headbutting it.
I guess people in this movie
just really like to break
things instead of opening them.
As we already mentioned, Sara
is just not the brightest.
I don't know how she even got accepted
into Haddonfield University,
because instead of going
to the lowest point
of the roof and jumping,
she goes back into the house to escape.
You know, the house where
the serial killer is.
I mean the roof isn't even that high.
It certainly seems safer to jump
rather than climbing over the body
hanging from the attic stairs.
For a moment there,
it looks like she's about to
Spider-Man kiss the corpse,
which is funny if you consider
that Spider-Man was still in theaters
when "Resurrection" came
out in July of 2002.
Freddie comes back to
the house to save Sara
and drops this line on Michael.
- So you wanna be on "Dangertainment"?
- Not only is that a terrible line,
but Michael's reaction
is certainly meme worthy.
You're in his house.
Imagine if I broke into someone's house
to ask them if they wanted
to be on "Things You Missed."
In true Rick Rosenthal
"Halloween" movie fashion,
it ends with Michael being lit on fire.
Things get a little bit dicey for Sara
when she gets pinned
down by, a mixing board?
Are you (censored) serious?
Anyway, Freddie saves her
by electrocuting Michael
Myers in the penis,
which sends him flying
across the room apparently.
It's good to know that
Michael's one weakness
is being electrocuted in the penis.
There are actually four
endings to this movie.
One where Michael comes
back to life on the gurney
and is immediately killed by
an ax that Sara somehow has.
One where she meets Deckard/Myles
in real life and he says...
- Well, you did it.
You killed the boogeyman.
(eerie music)
- You can't kill the boogeyman.
- Which is a callback
to Tommy Doyle's line
in the original movie.
- You can't kill the boogeyman.
(kid screams)
- And one where crime scene investigators
are let in by this cop, who
is played by Brad Loree,
the actor under the Michael
Myers mask throughout the movie.
That one ends with Michael
reaching out of the wreckage
to grab the investigator
as a one last scare moment.
Supposedly, Rick wanted to
send a different versions
of the film out to different
theaters so that the ending
you got could have been
any one of these four.
This tactic was used for
the 1985 film "Clue."
I actually think it's a cool idea,
but the studio rejected it,
probably realizing that it was a tactic
that would only build hype if
the movie was actually good.
- So the ending scene of the movie
shows Michael coming back
to life in the morgue,
which obviously finally gives meaning
to the title of "Halloween Resurrection."
I think that's why they
called it that anyway,
because there's no other resurrection
that happens in this movie.
This movie also went through
several different titles
before it came out.
We already mentioned
"Halloween Homecoming,"
but there was also "Halloween H2K,"
which I guess is a riff on Y2K,
which is kind of weird because
it happened a few years
before this movie came out.
And also, "Halloween: MichaelMyers.com."
Yes, "Halloween: MichaelMyers.com."
Wow, that is one of the
worst titles I've ever heard.
- Ultimately, I find it pretty funny
that they decided on "Halloween
Resurrection" though.
There's something so
ironic about "Resurrection"
being the one to kill your franchise.
"Halloween Resurrection" was so bad
that they decided to
end the 20-year timeline
and start fresh five years later
with Rob Zombie's remake of "Halloween."
However, we're gonna skip ahead
and talk about the 40-year timeline next.
So get ready, if you wanna hear everything
you might have missed
in "Halloween," 2018,
"Halloween Kills" and "Halloween Ends."
Look out for those new episodes
in the playlist on the left.
Thanks to Jimmy Champane
for joining me once again.
And remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week,
ring the death bell and
select all notifications.
And I will see you in the next one,
assuming we both survive.
Oh, we made it.
- We made it.
♪ "God Bless America" ♪